CAUSED IT TO SPIN OUT OF
CONTROL.
>> Bill: DANGEROUS SPORT.
I HOPE THEY ARE OKAY, RIGHT?
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY TO
MAKE HIS FIRST VISIT TO MEXICO
TO TALK ABOUT SECURITY CONCERNS
INCLUDING THE SURGE AND MIGRANTS
AT THE BORDER.
TODAY'S VISIT COMES AS BORDER
AGENTS FROM TEXAS WITH A STASH
HOUSE WHERE MORE THAN 100
MIGRANTS.
THE CONDITIONS DESCRIBED AS
INHUMANE.
BRANDON JUDD, THE PRESIDENT OF
CONTROL AND WELCOME BACK TO OUR
PROGRAM.
HERE IS MIKE POMPEO ON THE
POLICIES THAT WERE AND ARE NO
LONGER, WATCH.
>> IT IS NOT THE CONDITIONS DOWN
THERE TO CAUSE THE CURRENT
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
THE POLICIES OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS CAUSED
DEVASTATION TO THE HUMAN BEINGS
TRAFFIC ACROSS THE BORDER.
THIS IS NOT ONLY BAD FOR THEM
BUT BAD FOR THE UNITED STATES.
IT IS NOT A RESULT OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN CENTRAL AMERICA BUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Bill: I DON'T THINK HE
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT,
GOOD MORNING.
>> THERE WILL NOT BE MUCH THAT
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO DO.
WHEN YOU BLAME FOR HIS CURRENT
CRISIS CONDITIONS THAT AN ERROR
IN EL SALVADOR, GUATEMALA,
NEW MEXICO DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION YET
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ABLE
TO -- FOUR OR FIVE YEAR LOADS.
WHEN YOU MAKE EXCUSES, YOU WILL
NOT SOLVE THE CRISIS.
THERE ARE EASY SOLUTIONS RIGHT
NOW.
THERE IS JUST NOT THE POLITICAL
WILL TO DO WITH.
>> Bill: GIVE ME AN EASY
SOLUTION IN YOUR MIND.
>> HIRED JUDGES, HOLD PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY WITH A ASYLUM
PROCEEDINGS.
IF WE WERE TO DO THAT, WE WOULD
USE LEGAL PROCESS THAT IS
GERMANE, HOLDING PEOPLE IN OUR
CUSTODY, PINNING THEIR ASYLUM
HEARING AND THEN WE WOULD BE
DEPORTING PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
A RIGHT TO BE HERE.
WE WOULD BE GIVING RELIEF TO
THOSE WHO HAVE A LEGITIMATE
CLAIM TO ASYLUM.
THAT IS THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT
BUT YET, THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT DOING IT.
>> Bill: NEW MEXICO IT WORKED
OVERTIME.
FINALLY THESE GOVERNORS LOOKING
FOR MORE HELP.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT SUGGESTED LAST
WEEK THAT TEXAS START FINISHING
THE WALL.
I DON'T KNOW THE STATUS OF THAT
BUT PERHAPS YOU DO.
HERE IS PART OF THE LETTER
"SECURING OUR BORDER WITH MEXICO
IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION UNWILLING OR
UNABLE TO DO THE JOB.
OF COURSE, BORDER STATES LIKE
TEXAS GROUND ZERO FOR THE
CRISIS.
AND PROPORTIONATE.
HE'S IN BURDENS AND ADDITIONAL
MANPOWER NEEDED FOR IN A STATE
TO BE SPARED."
IT WOULD BE SOMETHING ELSE OF
OTHER STATES THAT WE COULD HELP
YOU WITH THAT.
>> GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS STEPPED
TO THE PLATE.
HE'S DONE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
GOVERNOR THAT I HAVE SEEN IN MY
ENTIRE CAREER.
HE HAS DEPLOYED TEXAS RESOURCES
TO THE BORDER.
SO WHEN WE HAVE BEEN OVERWHELMED
AND BORDER PATROL OVERWHELMED,
HE STEPPED IN AND FILLED THOSE
GAPS.
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO JUNE 10TH
AND WHAT VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
SAID WHEN SHE SAID THAT SHE
ADVOCATES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
ALIENS, THAT IS A CLEAR
INDICATOR THAT THIS CRISIS IS
GOING TO CONTINUE.
SHE IS ADVOCATING FOR
LAWLESSNESS.
SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE THAT
BEACON THAT SAYS, WE WILL HAVE
LOTS IN THIS COUNTRY THAT WE
WILL ENFORCE TO KEEP OUR
CITIZENS SAFE.
YET, SHE IS SAYING SHE IS
ADVOCATING FOR LAWLESSNESS.
>> Bill: BRANDON JUDD,
THANK YOU FOR COMING BY TOD